and
speaking of vesper that's what we did
last lecture
we're we're going to move on today but i
want to just clarify something about
vesper
um when i was talking about this i i
tried to put
two different concepts in the same place
and i put something in the table that
shouldn't have been there and
and people corrected me i want to be
sure that there's no confusion around
this
so what we had was a case of
formaldehyde
right and
we had the case of
so2
and i want to be really clear about this
both of these molecules when you're
thinking about vesper
the number the number
of electron domain count right remember
that's how we start
the number of of electron domains
is the same for both of them
right and we we did this on on wednesday
right and and if the number of electron
domains is the same then the electron
domain geometry
is trigonal planar right
okay but
i was
also telling you about repulsion order
at the same time and and so i put
i i put the wrong thing in the table and
then i race and i just want to be sure
we're clear
and we don't get bent out of shape about
it
stop get out of here stop stop it all
right
all right i'm gonna still be here i'm
gonna be here
all right so like here right the shape
remember what the table
what the table was about
was the number of lone pairs
okay the number of lone pairs and so if
i've got the three bonding pairs and no
lone pairs
then it's going to be a trigonal planar
shape so
that is trigonal planar and
over here i've got two bonding pairs
and one lone pair and so this shape
is called bent now what i did is i used
that word oh
why i don't know but you know you make
mistake when you're in the arena
you keep going and if you make a mistake
you admit it
you leave it all there you do your best
forget the rest that's all you can ever
do
now here's the thing i said bent i said
the word bent
and what i was talking about was how the
bends a little bit because of the
repulsion order
yeah but that that shape is not bent i
want to be real clear about that
that shape is trigonal planar and it's a
little bit distorted
okay this shape
is bent that shape is bent
and because it's a it's got a lone pair
remember the shape is about where the
atoms are
right but it's also a little bit
distorted
right because the lone pair pushes on
those guys
a little bit more right okay so that
those are the two concepts that i was
saying all at once and i want to make
sure we understand them
there's trigonal planar there's bent and
then there's repulsion order which talks
about a little changes in the angle from
those
parent shapes okay good all right now
on to today now here's the thing now
in in all this stuff with lewis
well it's a really good way to think
about molecules
but this tells me that there's electrons
on the bond
it tells me that there's electrons
really localized
in the region between the atoms but see
the thing is how much is it localized
how much is it really is it are these
electrons like
you know what if i were to draw the two
electrons though those dots like right
there
it doesn't really tell me the input more
information than that
but if we remember the the the picture
let's see if i can pull yeah there it is
there's a picture i showed you when we
first talked about covalent bonds
sharing is caring remember what happens
i've got the two protons and we talked
about these
a repulsion and then the two electrons
repulsion
and then i drew for you the fact that
but they can come together and they can
be like you know what you can use my
proton
for a little of your attraction and hey
can i use your
you know and they share it and each
electron sees both of them
and this is where those electrons are
but look at that the proton is there in
there and the electron
is in this probability cloud around both
of them
that's the molecular
orbital and lewis can't tell us about
that so we need something else and
that's what today's topic is about
today we're going to talk about
something called molecular orbital
theory
that gives us a sense of how these
atomic orbitals overlap
it gives us a much it gives us a much
better and more
deep a deeper description with more
details about these covalent bonds
okay all right now so let's write a few
things about
molecular orbital theory whole
molecular orbital and
what we're going to do is say m-o
molecular orbital theory so we'll keep a
list of some important things
all right well the first of all the
first thing is that atomic orbitals
atomic orbitals
or as we may call them aos
are the basis
for watch this efficiency the m os
i didn't have to write it again right
okay so what does that mean
well it means that i'm going to
construct the mo's
from the aos now the aos are the things
we've been playing with and making
right we solved the schrodinger equation
so the mo's
okay are going to be linear
combinations all right combinations
of the aos and that's why you might see
this
in fact
called lcao theory lcao
linear combination of atomic orbitals
okay and in particular
some and difference
of orbitals is what we're about because
you know
this is like what we talked about before
these are waves right these are waves
waves can can either constructively or
destructively interfere
and that's what we're going to explore
in ml theory by adding or subtracting
these wave functions these orbitals
these atomic orbitals
so that's enough to start let's see so
look basis
a basis is nothing more than the things
that i'm going to use
to represent the things that i want
right and the things that i want are
these molecular orbitals
the things that i'm going to use to
represent those are these
these beautiful atomic orbitals that we
spend a lot of time understanding and
developing
we'll start with the simplest case which
is
what i think i have oh i even
highlighted it and i said
let's first make molecular orbitals
using
combinations of the s orbital that's the
s orbital that's the 1s
orbital up there remember by the way
blue and orange is just the sign of the
wave
right this is not a charge please don't
make that
that confusion these are just waves
right waves
okay and the p orbital has let's go back
and see it p
orbital has a plus and a minus it's a
wave
all right and the s the 2s orbital has
that too
then you square it and you get the
probabilities right
okay so we'll start with 1s where it's
all just one sine
and i can add it i can add an s and
another s or i can subtract it
so let's do that right so we'll do that
over here
all right oh let's see so we'll do that
over here
so if i take a 1s
orbital and i add it to another 1s
orbital
well you can see as i bring these close
together
if they have the same sign these are
waves so if i if i if the waves are both
positive
and i bring them together they can
constructively interfere
so as i bring them closer and closer
well i might
actually get the picture that i showed
you right i might actually get
something that looks like this
okay i might actually get something like
this now if i
if i subtracted them then
as i bring these as i bring these
orbitals closer together
they're going to cancel each other and
you can see right here
if i bring these orbitals by the way
which are coming from two
different atoms right the whole point is
we're talking about molecules
molecular so if i bring them together
now like this
but i'm subtracting these orbitals
then you can see that right at the
interface right between them
it's always zero because i've just
subtracted the same amount no matter how
close they get
is zero that's a node right and in fact
what you're going to get is something
that looks like this
right now so what i've done is i have
i have added and subtracted the same ao
and i've created two mo's so these are
my mo's
and these are my starting aos that's
about the simplest thing you can do in
mo theory
i'm using these as a basis now there's
something very important
which is that this is i kind of already
alluded to this
these are two atoms coming together to
make a bond
this is the bonding axis this is the
bonding axis
okay now if an orbital if an mo
is symmetric okay
so if it has cylindrical cylindrical
symmetry about that bonding axis
then
it's called a sigma orbital it's called
a sigma orbital that's the mo
sigma is a notation a sigma orbital is
one that has symmetry around
the inter nuclear axis the two
ah
[Music]
we're coming to that very soon
because these are just the orbitals i
got to do something with them it's just
like over here
i made all these orbitals but then i had
to fill them
oh that got me excited
but see you can see right here when i
add them up
when i add them up there's charge in
between
so this looks like it's going to have a
bond
that's a bonding mo what but if i
subtracted them
this doesn't look very happy in terms of
like electrons
being in between and the carrying and
sharing principle of a covalent bond
right so if i were to put an electron in
this mo
it doesn't look bonding in fact it looks
or anti-bonding it's actually not quite
non-bonding we'll get to that later
this would be anti bonding
why because there's not even a
chance of electron density in between
yeah that's your starting principle of
the relationship
let's try to share oh by the way right
halfway no chance
that's not a very good way to start and
you can see why
this is an anti-bonding it's the
opposite you're actually pushing charge
away from the bond if you're in this
orbital if you're an electron in that
orbital so that's an antibonding
now we get to the question what do you
do with these orbitals well you make
them
i made these with one s
and the way that we typically draw
this is we go back to the same picture
that we've been working with 1s here and
1s here and i brought those orbitals
together and i formed
one that lowered the energy of the
system
and another that actually raise the
energy of the system because
the electrons are repelling they're
actually less bonding they're
anti-bonding
right
so these are my mo's
those are my aos right a-o-a-o
and and now this is called a sigma
orbital
and the way we refer to the anti-bonding
orbital is with a little star
they're both sigma because they both
satisfy that
right they're both sigma because they
both have symmetry around
the internuclear bonding axis but now
see okay
so that's good um
and but now let's fill them let's fill
them
right because now um
let's write let's write down the rules
and then we'll fill them for some
examples
okay so i'm going to keep going on my mo
theory list
right as you can see when i do it this
way the number of mo's
equals the number of aos used
to create them so that's one thing that
we can see right away
right i used two aos i added and
subtracted them i got two ammos
that's good another thing is
each mo will
be just like an ao
right it makes a lot of sense i had room
for two electrons here
i had room for two electrons here i
gotta have room for four
two here two here right so each mo
has a max of two
electrons and they must obey
pauli just like an
aos they must obey poly you can't mess
with quantum mechanics
uh-uh still electrons are still quantum
mechanical
right you're just making their wave
function more sophisticated
but they still have to follow the
schrodinger equation and the principles
of quantum mechanics
and so finally what we're going to do is
we're going to fill them
so we're going to fill the mos with
electrons
starting with the lowest energy just
like we did for atoms
lowest energy first
okay and one more thing just like we did
with adam
adams is we're going to obey hunt
ah hunt huns rule which tells you about
how to fill
degenerate orbitals well we're going to
have degenerate orbitals here too we
don't yet but we will
so we're going to fill them so let's
let's fill them for the very simplest
cases
okay so we'll do some cases together and
we'll see how that goes right so what
i'm going to do is four cases just so we
can compare
so first we're going to do h2 plus
okay that's that's the first one and
here
what we have is the
same graph but now over here
i actually can label it now this was
just an orbital but now it goes in tight
now okay well this is
the h this would be like h
and h plus okay these are my mo's
sigma sigma star 1s
1s oh boy but if i
so if that's h and that's h plus right
and they're coming together to make
h2 plus that's what's in the middle
there that's the molecule
right well then i also can now fill in
the starting aos
so let's do that
that's it because this one lost somebody
had to lose an electron to start with
we'll just represe
so now when these come together you fill
you you obey the
poly exclusion you fill from the lowest
energy first is that well i only got one
electron
there it is that's my mo diagram
populated by electrons
okay now there's a principle that comes
out of this
there's a way of understanding bond
strength now
there's a way of understanding
boundaries and and that is a very
important
concept now let's put it here in our
list let's put it here in our list
okay and it's a concept called bond
order
bond order now this one
i really want to write bo but i don't
know if that's good
a good idea so i'm gonna keep
i got laura in that one okay and that's
going to equal there's a definition for
this it's going to equal one half
of the number of electrons
in a bonding orbital in a bonding
orbital
minus the number of electrons in
an anti-bonding anti-bonding
orbital sorry this is a little bit small
here
but we'll do a bunch of them so you can
see what this means right so that the
bond order is important because
the bond order of a molecule right
so the bond order bond
order if it's higher
if it's higher than
stronger bond
and it has to be greater
and it has to be greater than zero
for stability let's see let's see how
that works
and i mean we'll we'll see this
intuitively as well as we fill these up
right so if i count the bond order here
oh i'm gonna do it i don't feel like
writing it out
the bo on this one is a half
times one minus zero which equals a half
okay good it's a half well it's greater
than zero
so right away i know that the h2 plus
molecule is probably stable that's good
but let's go to some more examples now
let's do a few more
all right now we're gonna work our way
to h2
and in this case energy is always going
up in these diagrams
now each of these h atoms is bringing an
electron there's no charge to the system
and so now
different quantum numbers paoli
different quantum but same sigma right
and so now that's the h2 now the b
the bond order here is equal to one
right i didn't have any electrons in an
anti-bonding orbital
all right but you know it's coming i'm
going to do h e2 plus next
and here what you're gonna see is
okay if i were let's do let's just put
it here for comparison
in real time if i were he2
each of these would be the ao occupation
of an he atom
right
and but since i'm he two plus one of
them is missing
an electron so this is what you're going
to see these are both he atoms still but
one of them is
is plus in this picture and
but see now okay i've got three
electrons they're going to go here
and i've got to put one up here
i have to because i had three i got to
keep on filling
just like in an atom but now i'm feeling
bonding
and anti-bonding orbitals all right and
here i've got this
and two up there
so if you look at the bond order here
the bond order is still positive here
the bond order is zero and in fact
that's why he2 is not a stable molecule
because you're putting just as much
charge on this thing that wants to bond
it as you are on this thing that doesn't
want to bond it
and at the end of the day it leads to a
molecule
that is not stable so that would be hg2
but he2 plus has a bond order
that's similar right
that's similar did i get something wrong
he two plus
one half ah
okay now because
this weakened it right this weakened
the molecule compared to this because
now i added charge to an anti-bonding
orbital so you would expect from the
bond order
that this one is more stable than this
and in fact it's what you find
right the h2 molecule has a stronger
bonding energy
now we can write the molecular
orbital configurations just like we did
with the atomic orbital configurations
okay and so like for here ah
right so for this case i'm gonna write
it up top if i can fit
so here we would have sigma 1s
and we're populating it with
ah that's not my example
this is my example
sigma 1s is the orbital and we're
populating it
with one electron right so that's how we
would write that
now if we go to the next examples we
would have
this one is this molecule
you would write as sigma 1s2
so this would be sigma 1s 2
and oh now i've got sigma 1
s 2 oh
this is getting interesting because now
it's sigma star
1s 1. everybody see that
all right i populate it's just like spb
but now i'm just filling those mo's up
and i'm
showing you what the molecular
configuration is
with those molecular orbital names sigma
1s sigma 1 star okay good
now we can keep going
we can do this all day um
actually we kind of will but we're going
to move on don't worry from sigma
um let's see let me go over here
now this is another concept that i want
you to know about mo theory
so
if you know so if i kept going
i could have for example uh let's do
lithium
okay so now lithium 1s oh ho
2s lithium brings
this what does it bring it brings three
electrons
and over here
1s and
2s three electrons so this would be the
lithium
dimer and but i want to make an
important point when you
would draw this one here's how i would
draw it
whereas when i would draw this one i
would draw it like this
okay now those are supposed to be the
same spacing i'll just
tell you in a second um the this notice
that the distance here between the
bonding and antibonding orbital is
larger
than it is here the reason is because
it's related to the overlap so there's
another point
which is that the overlap
of aos is
related so the let's say the greater
the greater the overlap of aoes
the greater the change
in energy
between bonding and anti-bonding
orbitals
ah between bonding and antibonding
orbitals
and let's be clear those are molecular
let's see you can see like if i'm
lithium those 1s's
aren't going to overlap too much right
they're kind of close to the core
so you do get mo there but the mo the
difference that you get
depends on how much these electrons are
near in energy and overlapping
and so so the 2s can overlap a lot more
okay now if i were to fill this up we
would get something like this
it's all these sigma 1s's oh
sigma 1 s
what do you think these are called
sigma 2 s sigma 2 s sigma 2 s
and this okay this is getting a little
bit i'm going to draw this out here
that's the sigma 1s star
right and this would be the sigma 2s
star
well what am i going to occupy well how
many electrons do i have to pour
into the molecular orbitals
hmm
lithium lithium two is stable because
its bond order
is you see bond order number of
electrons in
bonding orbitals one two three four
minus number of electrons and
antibonding
minus 1 2 divided by 2. so the lithium
dimer bonding
order is 1. all right and then you can
go on
and you can say well if i had beryllium
i'd have another electron here and here
and i'd fill those anti-bonding orbitals
up again like in the he2
dimer and i would have again an unstable
molecule which is in fact true
okay this is sort of the simplest
way you can think about molecular
orbital theory because it's the simplest
orbital
but you can go you can you can spend the
whole night and it is a friday
what else do you have this is what you
do on a
after i watch dr quantum
i'm gonna just add every single one of
these with every single one
it's finite it's not gonna take forever
let's just do p so okay now with p
orbitals there's something interesting
that happens because now
that sign you see how the p has a plus
and a minus right and so
you got to kind of think about that a
little bit
okay if i take a p orbital
and i'm going to take a i'm going to do
it like this
minus plus and i'm going to add it to a
p
orbital that looks like this and notice
i'm taking these and i'm adding them
along
an axis where they're kind of both along
the axis
right they're both along the axis and by
convention
by convention you know we'll do the pz
as the one along the axis remember
there's p x
p y and p z when we solve for the p
orbitals right those are the m's those
are the m's
right one zero minus one now
by convention we put the pz along the
bonding axis
and you can see right away you know so
if i do this well
i'm going to start adding these wave
functions constructively
and what you're going to get is let's
see if i can draw this
is something that looks like that
and where this is actually going to be
plus and this is minus and notice
that i'm going to have nodes in there
right i had nodes in the original
orbitals
but i got a lot of bonding in between i
got a lot of bonding density in between
that is a bonding orbital that is a
bonding orbital and and the other thing
we see about this is that
it is symmetric around that is so it's
actually
a sigma pz orbital it's a sigma
we call it a sigma because it's
symmetric around the bonding axis now
if i were to take a px oh well let's
actually let's subtract these
okay so minus plus minus
now what you see is something very
different right so now
oh boy can i draw this maybe
i don't know okay i'll take that
right and so now what you see so i'm
subtracting these and so the density
goes down
and now you're going to get minus minus
right
plus plus but but i've reduced the
electron density and even worse
i'm back to that situation where right
in between where i want to share the
most
i'm saying no no probability density
there
and that's an anti-bonding sigma p
orbital so this would be
sigma star pz okay
sigma star pz now the other thing that
you can
do is look at the the other directions
right
and so i'll just take one of those
really quick and if you do that
you see something different right so now
let's combine these like this
by the way some textbooks
we're adding and subtracting we're
constructively interfering
and destructively interfering yeah so
sometimes
you'll see a textbook add like this or
add
the other way which is subtracting like
this
this is the same thing right you can
decide how you want to orient it but
we're adding and subtracting
constructively and destructively that's
what we're doing
so i'm going to choose to add it like
this because then you can see if i do
this
then those are going to have some kind
of overlap
right those are going to have some
overlap of plus up here
and some overlap of minus up down there
and that is called oh
a pi orbital yeah
yeah but if i subtracted them then what
you would see is something that looks
more like this
where you got that node in between again
right
and this would be a pi star
orbital this would be for like px
orbitals now notice
these cannot be sigmas
because the pi orbital is not symmetric
around the bonding axis
okay these cannot be sigmas
but that's why we have another symbol
for them luckily we've got a lot of
symbols and the chemists are geniuses at
naming things
and so these are called pi orbitals and
as you can see that
you know okay i used i have three p
orbitals
one was i put it along the axis and i've
got two going
you know perpendicular in the other
plane and this is one of them and then
the other one would be
you know the other one p p y so
as you can see i'm going to have a sigma
a sigma star
two pi orbitals and two pi star orbitals
right and then what we got to do is we
got to put them on our energy
scale and instead of going through
drawing it all saving myself a few
minutes here
i'll show it to you right so there's the
energy scale
and oh they're pointing out the nose
isn't that beautiful you can see right
here
i had they're not saying what molecule
this is yet this is a 2p orbital
and and it's pointing along the same
bond
axis right as the other one so this is
going to be a sigma
p orbital this is a sigma p orbital
you can see that and there's a sigma
star right
good now if i go to that there's the
next one
there's a pi orbital and you get the
same exact effect you've got
a lowering of the energy because you're
putting electrons on the bond
and a raising of the energy because
you're taking them away
right and that's what it looks like for
the pi orbital
and we can put it all together and if
you put it all together
what i want to do is put it together for
o2 and then show you a video
and then do my why this matters
now if you um put this together i'm
going to show you
system for oxygen and nitrogen okay
and then we'll do one a couple other
cases too but we're going to do oxygen
first
so if i take oxygen then
i've got my two i'm gonna i'm not even
gonna write 1s anymore
that's way down in energy is not really
involved in the bonding
i'm going to leave it out but i've got
my oxygen
1s oxygen 1s okay
good so those are going to come in and
form molecular orbitals
like that and we know that they are all
filled
okay now but on now up here i've got my
oxygen sorry i just said i wasn't gonna
do 1s and i'm not those are 2s
those are 2s sigma 2s
sigma star 2s okay good all right
oh let's see now over here
i start with my piece and i start with
px right px
py pz and in oxygen how many electrons
do i have in here
so it's like this
everybody should be shouting
ah that was so much better that was
close
and then i've got them i'm not gonna
have enough room i've got
these over here
px py pz
and there is oxygen but you see now they
come together
and they form these mo's and we just
went over what types they are
right there's a sigma pz orbital and
there's a sigma
and but the ordering is about the same
thing that we learned which is that it
has to do
this delta is up there this delta is up
there
right and so in that pz for oxygen
you can overlap more it it pushes those
apart
more and so what you get is that
the pies are inside like that the pies
are inside right so this would be
i'm going to i'm right in here it's
going to get too small so i'm going to
do this
this would be a sigma 2p
z this would be a sigma
2pz star and
over here these would be
pi orbitals pi px
pi py and these
would be i almost can fit pi star
px and pi star py
all looking like the shapes that we've
been drawing right
and then the filling part comes from the
filling of the aos
right i've got my filling of the aos
here
i've got the valence filling for oxygen
there's a 1s down there
right and so i've got to put four
electrons from there and four electrons
from here
into the middle so let's do that one two
three four five six seven
eight paulie
paoli right
so for oxygen the bond order
if you add it up the bo
is two it's a double bond we know that
oh but now we know so much more and this
is what i want to make
that lewis could have gotten us this
but lewis can't get us magnetism
lewis can't get us magnetism molecular
orbital theory can
okay and let me show you magnetism right
up close
because if i take liquid nitrogen that's
not me though
and i pour it through a huge magnet
i want that magnet so badly but if i did
that
look at that liquid nitrogen just goes
right on
through and it's really fun to do
actually um
and so but there you go there that's
liquid nitrogen
but what happens look at liquid oxygen
liquid oxygen
now you pour it through and the magnet
holds it in place
right whoa is right
there's four more things we got to cover
one is paramagnetism
another is something called mixing
another is what happens when you go
heteronuclear oh yeah
see what that means in a second and
finally
what i said i would get to which is
non-bonding
which are not the same as anti-bonding
what i'm covering right now there is
paramagnetism
because as you saw on the exam in one of
the questions we explained it we said
if you got unpaired electrons
if you got unpaired electrons then
your para what does paramagnetism mean
it means that if you put a huge magnet
on it you respond you will feel a force
from that magnetic field
and so we did that in the exam we had a
silicon atom because we hadn't done
molecules but now we've got molecules
so i can tell you why that experiment
hap what's happening
i can tell you why that experiment
happens
really i didn't even know there was more
um
it happens because of hund's rule
molecular orbitals
and the fact that i've got these two
unpaired electrons in the o2 molecule
and you know that in nitrogen those two
electrons are gone because nitrogen is
missing one more here and here
so you've got two less everything's
filled
everything's filled paramagnetism now
now okay speaking of magnetism i
couldn't help but show you
this this is diamagnetism now
diamagnetism everything is filled but
you still feel a little repulsion to a
magnetic field
and some of you may know there's this
thing called the ignoble prize
only one person in history has won both
the ignoble and the nobel prize
andre geim who discovered graphene with
scotch tape
but before that he won the ignoble prize
because he did this to frogs
because water is diamagnetic
and so it repels the magnetic field this
has got to be really really really high
um i hope that frog was okay it looked
sort of okay so if the frog is floating
and it's like a study about levitation
using magnetism
why am i showing that to you no
particular reason
but this does get me to the why this
matters which has to do with how you
cook pasta
and of course of course
since we're talking about o2
when when i have finished cooking pasta
what do i do
i pour it there it is through it's like
it's sophisticated
i pour it through a colander that's a
membrane
that's a membrane you did use a membrane
you did a filter now but i could also
have done that separation
that same separation i could have left
it on the stove
i could have and it would have boiled
out
all the water and left me still with the
pasta separated from the water
i've accomplished the same exact thing i
have separated the pasta from the water
task done pasta may not taste as good
but you've done it but see the thing is
that if you separate things
this way versus that way you can just
feel how much less energy it's going to
take in fact you can save over 80
of the energy if you do a membrane-based
separation
as opposed to a thermal one because then
type
so those are two ways to separate
positive but see there's two ways to
separate lots of things
like how about one to ten nanometer
particles how about chemistry
how about molecules how do you separate
those
well you got the same two ways and if
you count up all the things we separate
this way it's a lot it goes on and on
and it will go all the way down the
infinite corridor
this is how we do chemistry in fact if
you have
has anyone seen this on the side of the
road
that's a distillation column it's a big
pasta cooker
that's all you're doing is boiling one
molecule off of another
over a long time with a whole lot of
fossil fuel
right in fact if you look at the u.s
energy consumption 30 roughly a third it
goes into industry
40 of that is for this one thing it's
boiling pasta but the pus
is one nanometer to 10 nanometer
particles
40 goes into boiling one chemical
species off of another
separation separation
that's that's 12 of all the energy
that's the same as every single drop of
gasoline in every single car
truck and bus that's just to give you a
sense of how much energy that is
i say well why aren't we using a
colander why don't we just pour it
through a colander like we do
our boiling pasta well we do that for
one field desalination
i got it why this matters on that
another time but we don't do it for all
those other things and there's a really
simple reason
we don't have the right pasta colander
we don't there's no option
for that size scale that can withstand
the conditions
that are in all of those chemical
separations but if we did
this we could we take so much
o2 out of the air we need o2
but we don't want the n2 so we have to
separate
how do we do it we go cryogenic we go to
very very cold temperatures which is the
same as boiling
right you're lower but you're still
spending all this fossil fuel to lower
the temperature
that's how much o2 we generate each year
right
and this is how much energy it takes
it's like half a percent of all u.s
energy
just to get but what if
you could use something like o2's
paramagnetism
what if you could use something about
the chemistry of o2
to do this separation more efficiently
lower energy or maybe make a new
colander that does that
and if any of you have ideas come talk
to me
this is a problem i care a lot about
okay
but i had some other paramagnetism
unpaired electrons we got that one
why is chemistry not why can't they
follow the rules
why but they they always got to break
them
and what we see was this was oxygen
sigma sigma s sigma sigma stars
pi pi star but look at what happens for
nitrogen
why because of something some people
like to call mixing
all it says remember i said that that
if we where did somewhere i said
that the closer an energy or the closer
in symmetry orbitals are
the more overlap they can have and the
more they interact and can mix
together in the ways that i've been
talking about yeah well it turns out
that if you go below oxygen in what are
called homonuclear dimers which is where
the atoms are the same
then you can get mixing even between
this sigma
and that sigma and so what happens is
instead of them being kind of separate
like this for n2
there's an interaction you see you can
think about the same way i'm throwing
more orbitals into the mix
and and so because they can contribute
to overlapping
you're changing that delta e even more
that's effectively what's happening
and so you can see this one for nitrogen
goes down
but that one goes up because that's the
delta e because it's able to mix in
it's able to mix in because they have
the same symmetry and they're closer
for those smaller atoms they're a lot
closer in energy
and so if you look at this what happens
is those
switch they switch it's real they switch
now it doesn't change the thing i just
talked about which is the magnetic
properties of n2
because they're still all filled but it
is
important because if i were to pull an
electron out of o2 i mean out of n2 it
would come
from a sigma orbital not a pi orbital
because of those interactions and those
happen below o2 so this is from your
textbook
and you see it says 2s2pz interaction
remember
2pz is sigma sigma same symmetry able to
mix
don't mix very well here but here
they're strong enough
to to change the ordering of that
orbital
and that orbital right see that
that's an important effect okay
all right now um so but it only happens
below o2
it happens below o2 because that's where
those energies
uh and orbitals can line up in that way
now there's two okay so we just covered
that now there's two more things
two more things and then that's all of
mo theory
one is i've been giving you the same
atoms but what if we go
from a homolog nuclear dimer to a
heteronuclear dimer which just means one
is one and one is another type of atom
how do we draw an mo diagram for that
and the second thing is what happens
the second thing is what happens in this
case
in hcl h is bringing only one
s electron to the party but cl is
bringing all of the
is bringing s is bringing p what does it
do
right how does the mo diagram look in
that case where i've got all these extra
electrons coming in
from one of the atoms right now i will
not do this in 30 seconds
but i will next week give you a nice
sort of thorough explanation for each
of these two last mo cases in the
meantime
have a very good weekend
you